IT TO HOMICIDE BUT IT REMAINS A
MYSTERY TO A DAY.
>> THE FIGHT KONLTSES BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AFTER ISRAEL
BANNED TWO CONGRESS PEOPLE TO
JOIN THE COUNTRY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUPPORTING THE
BAN.
>> President Trump: I'M ONLY
INVOLVED FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
THEY ARE VERY ANTI-JEWISH AND
THEY'RE VERY ANTI-ISRAEL.
I THINK IT'S DISGRACEFUL THE
THINGS THEY SAID.
YOU HAVE LISTS OF, THIS ISN'T
JUST A ONE-LINE MISTAKE.
WHAT THEY HAVE SAID ABOUT ISRAEL
AND JEWISH PEOPLE IS A HORRIBLE
THICK.
THEY'VE BECOME THE FAILS OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
>> ISRAEL REVERSED COURSE AFTER
THE CONGRESSMAN TALIB ASKED TO
VISIT HER FAMILY THERE.
TALIB REJECTED THE OFFER
CLAIMING ISRAEL IS TRYING TO
SILENCE HER AND TREATING HER
LIKE A CRIMINAL.
I FIND HER DECISION PERSONALLY
DEPLORABLE AND ALSO I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT AS GRANDDAUGHTER,
TOO, I WOULD GIVE ANYTHING TO
SPEND ONE MINUTE WITH ALL OF MY
DECEASED GRANDPARENTS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THERE'S SOME
TYPE OF STANCE SHE WOULD TAKE
NOW WHEN --
>> STUNNING.
>> IT IS.
SHE HASN'T SAID ANYTHING ABOUT
THE PEOPLE IN THE CHINA
CONCENTRATION CAMPS, MYANMAR, IF
SHE'S CONCERNED ABOUT THE
OPPRESSION OF MUSS 4RI78S AROUND
THE WORLD AND US TRYING TO
SILENCE HER, YET HOW IS THAT IT
SHE'S USING THE POSITION OF A
CONGRESSMAN HERE AND CAN
LEGISLATE WHEN SHE NEEDS TO BE A
LOUDER POSITION THAN ANY OF US
HAS.
>> SHE WROTE A LETTER SAYING SHE
CARELY NEEDED TO SEE HER
90-YEAR-OLD GRANDMOTHER.
ISRAEL APPROVED, THEN SHE SAID
I'M NOT GOING TO USE IT.
SHE USED HER I WILL DEARLY
GRANDMOTHER AS A PROP FOR A
STUNT.
THE TRIP SHE WAS PLANNING ON
GOING WAS PUT TOGETHER, PLANNED
WITH AN ANTI-SEMITIC GROUP.
IF SOME ONE IS GOING ON YOUR
HOUSE, SPECIFICALLY TO VAPDLIZE
IT OR DESTROY IT, YOU SHOULDN'T
HAVE THEM THERE.
TO USE YOUR GRANDMOTHER AS A
TROJAN HORSE, IS DISGUSTING.
>> I TELL YOU WHAT IS
DISGUSTING, PRESIDENT TRUMP
GOING TO A FOREIGN COUNTRY AND
SAYING THAT A MEMBER OF OUR
CONGRESS, THE AMERICAN CONGRESS,
DULY ELECTED, CAN'T TRAVEL TO
YOUR COUNTRY AND OUR PRESIDENT
IS WORKING AGAINST THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT?
>> I DON'T THINK IT HAPPENED
THAT WAY.
>> IT HAPPENED EXACTLY, HE'S ON
THERE, PRESSURING NETANYAHU,
MAKING A POLITICAL DEAL, DRAWING
IN FAVORS, HE WANTS TO MAKE
THESE FOUR THE FACE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> THEY ARE.
>> THE HOUSE MAJORITY CLEARLY
VOTED AGAINST ALL POINTS AND
DIVESTMENT IN ISRAEL.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF ISRAEL.
MOST JEWISH PEOPLE VOTE
DEMOCRATIC.
THE REPUBLICANS SAYING THIS WAS
A MISTAKE MR. PRESIDENT.
THE REACTION IS SO SEVERE AND SO
MANY CORNERS AND YOU WANT TO
SAY, LET ME TELL YOU, SHE'S
POSITION TURING, I AGREE --
POSTURING, REACTION TO THE FACT
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ACTING
IN SUCH AN OBNOXIOUS AND RUDE
AND POLITICAL MANNER.
>> THE OBNOXIOUS IS ALL OF THE
SQUAD.
>> WHEN PELOSI TRIED TO FLYLE
OVERSEAS DURING THE SHUTDOWN,
THIS REMINDS ME.
TRUMP SAID I'M GOING TO GROUND
HER PLANE AND NEGOTIATE THIS
DEAL.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED, HE PULLED
THE RUG OF THE FROM UNDER HER,
THEY WEREN'T GOING ON A
FACT-FINDING MISSION, DIPLOMATIC
MISSION, THEY WERE GOING TO
CAUSE TROUBLE.
HE SAVED US ALL THE TROUBLE,
GOODBYE.
THE GROUP THAT SPONSORED THEM IS
ALMOST A HATE GROUP.
YES, JUAN THAT, HASN'T BEEN
REPORTED.
NOTICE WHO DIDN'T GO ON THE
TRIP, AOC.
WONDER WHY.
NANCY WHEN SHE HAD 19 OON 1 WITH
AOC AFTER THOR CAN FLUFL
PROBABLY SAID YOU'RE A RISING
STAR, SMART WOMAN, SPRAPT YOUR
STEPH FROM THE REST OF THOSE
PEOPLE, THEY'RE NOT DOING YOU
ANY GOOD.
>> OH MY GOSH.
>> SUPPORT FOR ISRAEL USED TO BE
BIPARTISAN THING.
AND JUST TWO WEEKS AGO, WITHIN
THE LAST WEEK, I THINK 51
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS, WENT TOGETHER
WITH APAC.
THESE TWO DECIDED NOT ON GO WITH
THEM.
THEY COULD HAVE GONE WITH THIS
GROUP, THIS IS SEPARATE, MEANT
TO SEPARATE.
SO, THERE'S THE TRUMP PART,
PEOPLE CAN LOOK AT THIS AND
ARGUE WITH IT.
AGAIN.
TRUMP, HE'S NOT AFRAID ABOUT THE
BLOWBACK, HE DOESN'T CARE.
I DON'T CARE.
BUT NOW WHAT IS HAPPENING,
ACTUALLY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC ISSUE.
ABOUT THE POSITION THAT THEY
TAKE ON ISRAEL.
ON THE BDS MOVEMENT.
SO HE DOESN'T CARE, GOING AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THIS, IS
FUTILE F YOU'RE THE DEMOCRATS,
YOU HAVE TO START ANSWERING, YOU
AGREE WITH THAT, DO YOU AGREE
WITH THEM, DO YOU AGREE WITH
THEM.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ASKED.
I CANNOT THINK OF A SINGLE DAY
SINCE JANUARY 1 WHEN THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN ON
OFFENSE ON A SINGLE MEDIA NEWS
CYCLE.